Speaker 1: Let's go. Let's go to Noah
from California. Noah, you're on the air.
Speaker 3: Hi, can you hear me? Yes, I can.
All right. Hey, David. Longtime listener,
first-time caller. Thank you. Well, I just had a
question if if you've noticed, I heard you talk
the other day that you said crypto seems to be
a trigger word for a lot of people on the left.
And I feel like I've been seeing that happen with
Tesla and Elon Musk as well, people trying to
brag on his engineering of the vehicles
and saying that it's badly designed this.
I mean, I thought we were supposed
to be pro electric vehicle, right?
Yeah, I just I don't understand it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, listen,
I don't know that I'm the right person to comment
on this as both a, you know, Tesla vehicle owner
and longtime shareholder, I quite frankly,
couldn't care less about Elon Musk. I mean,
you know, my car has been perfect.
There's no problems with it. It
works fine. Every feature works fine. I've never
had any problem. The car needs no maintenance.
It has, you know, we most vehicle
manufacturers, we're doing electric vehicles.
Still don't have vehicles with range anywhere
close to what Tesla has, but I do agree that soon
Tesla is going to have a problem on its hands.
One of those problems is that I mean, listen,
Audi is better at making cars than Tesla. That's
just the reality. And right now, the Audi e-tron
gets 200 miles per charge. But later this year,
they're going to have one that gets closer to 400
miles per charge once that's the case. Are people
going to get the e-tron or the Model Y? I mean,
probably the e-tron, you know, so. So I think that
there's legitimate criticisms of the vehicles,
there's criticisms of the company. The company
is getting sued for certain things and everything
should all happen. I don't really care about
the cult of personality stuff. I mean, I think,
you know, Elon Musk needs to pay taxes and Elon
Musk needs to do all the things everybody needs
to do. But yeah, for me, it's like people just
get so emotional about this stuff. It's like,
I don't care about Elon Musk, I don't care about
Sergei Brin or Zuckerberg specifically. It's
just sort of like, what are these companies
doing? What are they bringing to the table?
Are they properly regulated, et cetera? Elon
Musk's wacky tweets? Yeah, I find them stupid,
but I just don't really care, you know?
Speaker 3: Right, right. I pretty much
agree with everything there, I just have a quick
follow up. What do you think about these electric
trucks coming out? I think it was Ford or Chevron
or something that just released them. Do you have
any opinions about that? Would you be getting
an electric truck if given the opportunity?
Speaker 1: I don't need a truck. I mean, you know,
growing up, I had friends who had pickup trucks,
and I would always say, What do you need the bed
for? And they'd say, Oh, every once in a while
I move something I just don't. I just don't
need a truck, so I don't plan to get a truck.
But I think it's fantastic. And the fact that
there is such demand for the electric F-150
bodes really well for electric vehicle adoption.
I think it's great. I think we just need to be
moving towards electric vehicles, period.
Speaker 3: Completely agree. Thank you,
David, for answering my call.
Speaker 1: My pleasure. There is
Noah with some very pointed questions
about Tesla and and other things